[MUSIC PLAYING]
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: Hi, everyone.
My name is Raleigh Seamster,
and I'm a program manager
with Google Earth Outreach.
I'm really excited about the
guest we have here today.
I'd like to introduce to
you Cris Stainbrook, who's
the President of the Indian
Land Tenure Foundation.
And he's here today to talk
about the past, present,
and future of Indian lands
in the United States.
Please welcome Cris.
[APPLAUSE]
CRIS STAINBROOK:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
Cris Stainbrook, emaciyapi.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], Raleigh.
Good afternoon.
My name's Cris Stainbrook.
And thank you to
Raleigh for inviting
me to do a Google talk.
You can tell by my
southern Lakota accent
that that would make me Oglala.
And I'm sure you're
familiar with that, right?
So today we're going to
talk about Indian land
and Indian land specifically
in the United States, the lower
48.
We won't talk about Alaska,
because the land issues are
entirely different up there,
although they do share
some amount of commonality.
Most of our work has been
limited to the lower 48.
The Foundation itself
started nearly 16 years ago,
and we started with a mission.
And then those areas
outside of the boundaries
that have special
meaning to the tribes
still, either for cultural
reasons or religious reasons.
This is Indian land before
the coming of the Europeans.
It was the entirety
of the continent,
about 800 different tribes,
and went from sea to sea,
basically.
Then we had the early
immigration period
where we had the 13 colonies
established and the Europeans
coming onto the shores.
And that went through
pretty much the late 1600s.
And then we started
getting even more pressure
from Europeans and others coming
to the shores on the East.
And eventually, it led to
President Andrew Jackson
declaring that all
Indian people should
be removed from the East, at
least to the Mississippi River.
And in fact, that's
when Oklahoma,
what's now the
state of Oklahoma,
became Indian country,
and they removed people
from the eastern
tribes to Oklahoma.
That's why you see the
tribes in Oklahoma today
being the same ones that
were on the East Coast.
In theory but not
in practicality,
the land rights of those
tribes on the East Coast
were eliminated or eradicated.
Then we started getting people
coming on the West Coast.
We had the Hudson Bay Company.
We had people looking for
gold and furs and others,
and we started getting pressure
in Oregon and California
specifically, but also
Washington State to a lesser
extent.
It was also in
1803, of course, we
had the Lewis and Clark
incursion up the Missouri River
and over the Rocky
Mountain Divide
and into the Pacific Northwest.
All of this kind of got to
a point of what's called
manifest destiny.
So it was this notion
that all folks,
all the immigrant
folks had about,
they were destined to
take over this country.
You can see by this
particular picture,
you've got this angelic
figure, of course,
stringing the telegraph wire.
You've got the bears
and Indian people
and Buffalo running
in fear further west.
And you get the
railroads coming in.
You've got industry, as it were,
pushing people out of the land.
Which then led to any number
of Indian wars and settlements
and peace treaties and other
treaties that were primarily
land sessions to non-Indians.
And today, this is
largely what you
would see if you looked at
a map of the treaties that
were done through 1871, which
ended the treaty-making period.
One thing I would point out--
and this map needs a little
work--
I was showing this
at the Crow tribe.
I was showing it to
a family of folks
who wanted to work out an
agreement with the Crow tribe
around land that they owned,
and I popped the slide up.
And unfortunately, if you look
at the southeastern boundary
of Montana, the Crow reservation
and the northern Cheyenne
reservation were
left off the map.
And now they blame that
on me being Oglala.
[LAUGHS]
You know, it was
just an oversight.
What can I say?
If we want to summarize the
land loss up to that point,
it's easy to do
it up until 1887.
So in 1871, the
federal government
quit making treaties
with tribes.
And after that, reservations
were established
by executive order only.
There were a number of
those between 1871 and 1887.
In 1887, the reason
that's important
is because that's when
Congress and others decided
that Indian people should become
farmers and ranchers, much
in the European mode.
So what they did was they passed
the Dawes General Allotment
Act.
And the Dawes
General Allotment Act
said the reservations
would be allotted
to individual Indian
people in 80, 160,
or 320-acre allotments.
And on those allotments,
Indian people
would learn to be
farmers or ranchers.
And all the tribal
lands would basically
be extinguished at that point.
At that date in 1887, we had
130 million acres of land
inside the reservation
boundaries,
and almost every treaty
reads for the exclusive use
and occupation by Indian people.
And there was an acre or two
set aside for the blacksmith,
there was an acre or two set
aside for the schoolmarm,
and there was an acre or two
set aside for the agency.
Other than that, it was
to be entirely reserved
for Indian people and their use.
By 1934, when the
Indian Organization Act
passed to put an end to
the allotment process,
it was recognized by
a 1928 Meriam Report
to Congress that
said the Allotment
Act is an abysmal failure.
It's created poverty.
And Indian people have not
become farmers and ranchers
in the mode that
they anticipated.
And so at that point, they
stopped the allotment process.
And basically, we
had 48 million acres
of land left inside
reservation boundaries.
The rest had been alienated
to other ownership.
And I give you a
quick breakdown.
The 90 million acres that were
lost, about 60 million got
lost immediately.
38 million went to
what's called ceded
to the federal government.
Once they did the allotment
process at each reservation,
if there was land that
had not been allotted--
so they did an allotment to
every head of the family,
and if there was
land left over, they
declared it in excess
of Indian needs,
and the federal
government took it.
And so that was the big loss.
That was 38 million.
Actually, that was 60.
The other 22, they were
open to homesteading.
And so 22 million acres
was open to homesteading,
and immigrants moved in.
The other land that went
to the federal government
was held or sold.
So they went to timber
companies or railroad companies,
mining companies.
Or the federal government
retained ownership
if no one else wanted it.
So that's where the land went.
And then we lost
30 million acres
through a whole host of
other means, usually sale.
So Indian people would
get impoverished,
they would be buying
commodities at the agency store.
In order to pay off
their bill, they'd
end up selling their land
interest to the store.
The other way-- a couple of
other ways that land was lost
is the Dawes Allotment Act
had a blanket declaration
of all Indian people and
tribes as incompetent
to handle their own affairs.
And when they did that, they
converted the land title
from Indian ownership to
federal trust ownership.
And the federal
government holds land
in trust for those individuals
and for the tribes, any land
that was left to the tribes.
And so the federal government
then oversaw those pieces.
Starting in 1903, the
federal government
decided that some
Indian people should
be declared competent to
handle their own affairs.
So for instance, if an Indian
woman married a non-Indian man,
she was declared competent.
And some of you may
have seen the movie
that just recently came out.
We lost lots of land in
Oklahoma because Indian women
married non-Indian men, and
then within a six-month, year
period, met with an accident.
And we lost lots
of Indian women,
and we also lost
lots of Indian land.
The other way that really
hits a little closer to home,
and especially it happened in
the Upper Great Plains tribes,
is Indian men
could be declared--
I should first go back and
say if an Indian man married
a non-Indian woman,
that was seen as kind
of lateral incompetency.
[LAUGHS]
I'm sorry, but that's
just the way it was then.
So an Indian man could
become declared competent
if he joined the military.
And so in World War I, we
had any number of Indian men
who were warriors by
nature signing up and going
to the military.
And what happened
when they did that,
they were declared competent.
They would come home
four years later
and find out that they had
been declared competent
and the taxes had
started to mount on what
they thought were trust lands.
But since they declared
them competent,
they had become fee land
and taxable by the county.
And so while they
were fighting at war,
the county sold their land
on the courthouse steps,
basically, through a tax sale.
And we lost millions
of acres that way.
They're called
forced fee patents.
So by declaring the incompetency
of the federal government
or the Indian people
and dividing the land,
in doing all that,
it never occurred
to the federal government
that allottees would die.
And so the original
allottees started to die,
and there was no
way, no mechanism,
because they were
declared incompetent,
to handle their estates.
And so they had to
come up with a process.
And they came up with
a process that said,
the land will remain connected.
But the land will
remain intact, but we'll
divide the ownership interests
as we go down the road.
And eventually, you
know, all of the land
will somehow, in essence,
end the holding of the tribe.
And so Teddy Roosevelt in 1901
declared "The General Allotment
Act a mighty pulverizing engine
to break up the tribal mass."
I mean, this was an attempt.
The Dawes Allotment and
all the allotment processes
were arranged so that
eventually, the tribe
no longer exists.
And that was the intent
of the whole direction
of the country at that time.
And Teddy Roosevelt
was a big believer.
So what did the allotment
process look like in practice?
This is the Salish-Kootenai
reservation,
a Flathead Reservation
in Northwest Montana.
Two tribes were
there, the Salish
and the Kootenai in the
1855 Hell's Gate Treaty
set to the side.
You can see that green portion
is all tribal ownership.
And you can see the
entirety of the reservation
is under tribal ownership.
Allotment process
came in late 1900s.
And in fact, in 1908 and
'09, I think, was completed.
And so this is the yellow
in the valley there.
The Salish people were
more mountainous people.
If you know this
area at all, you
know there's a mountain
range that runs down
the east boundary and a
mountain range that runs down
the west boundary, and
down toward the bottom
is essentially the valley
outlet toward Missoula, Montana.
Those were the allotments.
They were selected by
the families themselves.
So then it gets opened
up to homesteading.
And all of the white,
all of the gray, all
of those other squares that are
on there, the purple and others
were taken from the tribe, even
though this land specifically
was reserved for the
exclusive use and occupation
by Indian people.
Since that time, they've
lost a little more land,
but they've also been buying
back land and beginning
to get it back into tribal
ownership or members.
I think this is one
of those pieces that
deserves a little noting.
The big purple
circle in the bottom
is the National Bison Range.
It was established
at the time of--
well, just after Teddy
Roosevelt was president.
Interestingly enough,
the Salish-Kootenai folks
had a buffalo herd for years
and years in their area,
and the only way they saw
to save it from non-Indians
killing all the buffalo is they
sent their buffalo to Canada
and raised them up there.
When they established
the National Bison Range,
they brought the
buffalo, their buffalo
back down to the Bison Range.
For the past almost
20 years, the tribes
have been trying to take over
management of the Bison Range
from the US Fish and
Wildlife Service,
and have been fought tooth
and nail, even though it's
their land and their buffalo.
This is a more egregious
example of what happened
under the Allotment Act.
This is the Leech
Lake Reservation
in North Central Minnesota.
The little red dots
you see over that map,
those are tribal trust, tribal
and individual trust lands.
And that's all that
remains of their ownership
on the reservation.
All of the rest of the land
is owned by non-Indians.
Largest landowner on the
Leech Lake Reservation
is the federal government
through a national forest.
Second largest is
a state forest.
And then after that, it
becomes municipality and then
other non-Indian individuals.
You can see that that's a
very small piece of land
that the tribes and Indian
people actually own.
Even though, if you
drive up on the highway,
there's a big sign on
every highway that says,
you're entering the
Leech Lake Reservation.
And people think, wow.
Indian people have
all this land.
It's pretty impressive.
But that's what we find.
As I said before, there was no
real process for inheritance,
and they had to develop one.
And so they developed
that piece where it said,
we're going to hold
those allotments intact,
and the title will
divide among the heirs.
And their first efforts at
this were not very good,
but they looked kind of this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Going back to
the Allotment Act,
my great grandparents might have
picked up a 160-acre allotment
or 640 acres.
When they passed on, and let's
say they had four children,
those land interests
were divided by four.
And when those people passed
on and they had children,
the land was further divided.
And if there wasn't a will or
some mechanism for, you know,
allocating the land interest,
over and over again,
you had a continued division
into smaller and smaller
pieces.
So take a pie.
You divide it in half.
You divide it in quarter.
Divide it eights, divide
it 16, 1/32, 1/64.
All of a sudden, how much a
piece of the pie do you have?
You don't have a lot
of piece of the pie,
but you still have an interest.
[END PLAYBACK]
CRIS STAINBROOK:
We have people--
we have allotments with more
than 5,000 owners on 80 acres.
Now there aren't very many
of you in the audience today,
but can you imagine just
taking this audience
and sitting down
and saying, what
should we do with our land?
Then think about doing that with
200 of your closest relatives
at Thanksgiving.
And then think about it
in getting a gymnasium
and bringing 5,000 of your
relatives, some of who
you're undoubtedly not even
familiar with, to a gymnasium
and sitting down and saying,
should we lease our land,
or what should we do with it?
Well, what happens is it
by default starts getting
managed by the Bureau of
Indian Affairs or others,
or it gets sold.
And that's where we're at today.
We have from some
information we received
from the Department
of Interior, we
have one woman
who's 45 years old
and owns 345 undivided interests
on four different reservations.
But you total it up, and
she owns about 80 acres.
And we have 1,000 landowners
who own 100 interests or more,
some on as many as
12 reservations,
and some where that 100
undivided interests doesn't add
up to more than
1,000th of an acre,
which essentially is a
five-by-five-inch notepad.
It's a chaotic
morass, if you will,
and it's up to the Bureau of
Indian Affairs to manage that.
The problem we have, the
fundamental underlying problem
we have is that
all the tribes have
been very much a
land-based culture
where you are open and free
to exercise your activities
on the land and [INAUDIBLE].
And it was important
for the tribes
when they negotiated
treaties to maintain
that access to property,
both around the reservation
as well as in it.
They're our homelands.
Clearly, they're our homelands.
The other piece that
sometimes gets overlooked
in just having
those reservations
is that people were often
moved from another site
to that reservation, removed
from an area that was given up
or ceded to the
federal government.
There are religious
sites outside
of the reservation boundaries
where the tribes still
maintain interests.
On the Columbia River,
they're fishing sites.
In the Midwest, they're
promontories and what's
called Devil's Tower, Bear
Butte, some of those places
where the tribes gathered for
Sun Dance and other activities.
In the Southwest, you've got
major canyons and other areas
that have some feature that
drew the tribes there, or had
some amount of importance
in terms of trade.
So in the Pacific
Northwest, you had
what's called the old
Seneca race track.
It's in east central Oregon.
The tribes from both
the Intermountain West
and the Pacific
Northwest gathered there.
They'd have horse races,
but they would trade.
And that's where obsidian began
to move from the Crater Lake
area to the Plains was
through that trade corridor.
So this is our vision
of where we want to go.
We had a gentleman in our office
one day who was an artist,
and he was asking if he could
do some work for us, because he
needed a few dollars.
And we happened to
walk by the earlier
picture of manifest destiny.
I said, well, you could
paint our version of this.
[LAUGHS]
And I'm was kidding
him, but he did it.
So you can see we've got our
own angelic figure, picking up
the telegraph wire.
We've got that
accomplished pretty much.
But we've also got
pipelines laid down,
the railroad's there.
But you can see our vision.
We know we aren't getting
all of our land back.
That's not our intent.
What we want is
what was promised
to us, those lands inside
the reservation boundaries
that were promised to us for
the exclusive use and occupation
by Indian people.
The Foundation pursues
four strategies.
Education, economic
opportunities,
cultural awareness,
and legal reform.
And I'm going to go through
some of these fairly quickly.
So one of the things that we
started with was education.
We did that because
Indian people as well
as non-Indian people know
very little about Indian land.
In Indian country, we've
been separated from that land
for so long that we
aren't even sure--
most people in Indian
country aren't even sure,
how did we get in
this situation?
If you ask some
folks, they think
that it's part of the treaty
that we have allotments.
You know, they think
it's a treaty right
to have that allotment,
and it's not that at all.
We get folks to understand
that one of the big pieces,
because of that fractionated
ownership that I described
to you, we've been writing wills
for Indian people since 2003.
Part of the reason
we do that is there's
no history in Indian country
of writing wills and passing
your interests along.
Because we were declared
incompetent until 1903,
we weren't allowed
to write wills.
And in fact, it wasn't till
1924 when Indian people were
recognized as citizens
of the United States,
a will wouldn't
hold up in court.
And so there was
no history of that.
Our best guess is 7% of
Indian people have wills.
And we're trying-- we've been
trying hard to get that up.
We also do strategic
land planning
with the tribes and
others on a regular basis.
We put out a message
runner on, I would say,
a periodic basis
on various topics
that Indian country
needs to know about.
But this one was one
of our first ones,
and we've got one since
then, that's really
about the general public.
And you can find those online.
The other thing we did
was we ask ourselves,
so our mission is
one of 150 years.
That's our plan.
We aren't going to be
around to see 150 years.
And so we ask ourselves, how
do you get a movement started?
And one of the things
that we looked at
was the nonsmoking movement,
the recycling movement.
You know, what were
at the heart of those?
And it was the kids, right?
So the kids, you get this
message across to them and say,
you don't want to start smoking.
And they would take that
home to the parents.
And so that's where we started.
We have a K through
12 curriculum.
We have a college curriculum.
And we were approached about
doing a Head Start curriculum.
In fact, we have a
coloring book now
for Head Start on Indian land.
Our curriculum is in about--
well, it's in all
the states of Montana
or all the schools in Montana.
It's in most of the schools
in South Dakota now.
And it's in-- jeez, I don't
know what the count is now.
50 or 60 schools in California.
Primarily Southern
California, and then very
Northern California, up
in Yurok and Round Valley.
The other thing we
did on a lark was
a gentleman came to our
office one day and said,
I want to help you.
And we said, well,
what do you do?
And he said, well, I'm in
the entertainment industry.
And we said, OK.
But what can you do for us?
And he said, well, I'll
help you raise some funds.
And we said, well,
you know, we aren't
ready to raise a bunch of funds.
And he said, well, I can
make a movie for you.
And we didn't know
him from Adam.
Our support person out front
said, was that Barry ZeVan
the weatherman that was there?
And it turns out, he was the
weather man in the Twin Cities
for a number of years before
he went to Washington and New
York.
He gave us a good
price on doing a film.
We did the film.
He arranged to have Sam
Donaldson narrate the film.
And it turns out that we won
the Telly award that year
for documentaries.
And we've been happy ever
since about that, since we
knew so little about it.
They called us and said,
you won the Telly award.
And we said, what's that?
[LAUGHS]
We have a Buick hood ornament
that-- or I should say,
it looks like a
Buick hood ornament.
This is one of the big pieces.
Every time the federal
government realizes
they have a problem
with fractionation,
the way to solve it is
put it on Indian people.
And so in 2004, the American
Indian Probate Reform Act
passed.
And it basically
set up a process
that if Indian people
don't have wills,
they lose control
of their asset.
And the federal
government decides
how their asset will
go, to be divided
among their heirs or not.
We are going to lose a
whole bunch of Indian land,
three generations
out, if we can't
get people to write wills.
So we spend an
inordinate amount of time
trying to do pieces around the
American Indian Probate Reform
Act.
Then we also work on using
land as an economic asset.
How do you leverage
your land ownership?
How do you use that land
to be productive and make
a living off of it?
And we've done a
number of things,
including acquiring the
alienated properties
inside reservation
boundaries, and also helping
some amount of agricultural
businesses to get started.
Because ag, of
course, is the most
tightly connected to the land.
And in the Great Plains,
it takes large acreages
in order to make a living.
So we've been working on doing
some buffalo operations which
require astoundingly
large tracts of land.
We also have a subsidiary, the
Indian Land Capital Company.
And it lends to the tribes
in full faith and credit.
We don't take collateral
from the tribes.
We don't take land
as collateral.
Once they have
that land back, we
are not going to put
it in jeopardy again.
We wanted to demonstrate that
in fact, the banks should
be lending to the tribes
on full faith and credit.
On the other hand, they
seemed reluctant to do that.
But what we've demonstrated
to them is that, in fact,
you can do this, and the
tribes will repay the loans.
And we have not had
a default. We've
had one tribe get in
trouble, and that was a loan
that we rewrote for them,
and they paid it off early.
The other thing that's
become interesting
is much of our
early capitalization
for Indian Land Capital Company
came from banks as EQ2 loans.
So meeting their CRA challenges,
their Community Reinvestment
Act challenges,
that was a way they
could make a low-interest loan
to Indian Land Capital Company,
and then we would relend it.
This year, we will get
Indian Land Capital Company
to about a $53 million business.
We've been running
just below $10 million.
And the banks, two of the banks
won't lend us any more money
to relend, because they
said we're now competitors.
And these are banks that dwarf
Indian Land Capital Company.
I mean, dwarf it.
Big national banks and
international banks.
But it's interesting.
They could, in fact,
lend the same way.
They lend to the state set
through full faith and credit,
and they could certainly
lend to the tribes that way.
The other thing we started
working on with the Intertribal
Ag Council that we hope will
afford the tribes and others
the opportunity to
benefit from their land,
we're doing it through
the National Indian Carbon
Coalition, which was set up to
help the tribes and individual
landowners be able to
access carbon markets.
So here in California, you
have one of the largest
cap and trade markets.
We worked with the California
Air Resources Board
to understand that some of the
provisions they were putting
in their regulations on who
could access that market just
weren't going to
fly with the tribes.
So having the tribes
have to approve
all of the projects inside
the reservation boundaries
was going to limit anybody
living in the reservation
boundary from probably using
the tribal sovereignty in order
to do those projects.
We got some of that changed.
Right now, we've really moved
this quite a ways along.
We're working with
Best Buy and a number
of other local entities
in the Twin Cities
to reduce their carbon market
or their carbon footprint,
if you will.
It's not about offsetting
pollution as specific source
pollution, but rather their
carbon footprint overall.
The other place, when we
first started the Foundation,
we had a long debate about,
should this particular strategy
be using land to help
Indian people rediscover
their culture?
Or should it be
discover their culture?
And during that
whole conversation,
it finally came
down to discover.
Because as I said
earlier, in many cases,
we've been so disconnected
from our land for so long
that we don't even know
that culture anymore.
One of our very first
grants from the Foundation
went to a tribe in Oklahoma.
And they couldn't-- they
wanted to go back and document
their culture.
And specifically,
they wanted to know
why they did an acorn
dance when they had no oak
trees on their reservation.
Well, it turns out they
were removed from Ohio.
And in Ohio, they had
all these oak trees,
and that's why they did
this oak dance in the fall.
And for them, it was
kind of a revelation of,
you know, well, we've
adapted, but we haven't
left all of our culture behind.
For the most part,
we've been moving
toward preserving rather than
use some of our other pieces
on this particular slide we've
been moving toward getting out
there and preserving those
places where the tribes still
have a cultural interest.
This happens to be Pe' Sla.
Pe' Sla is a Lakota name.
It means the heart
of everything.
And this is a big prairie in
the middle of the Black Hills,
which of course was reserved
through 1868, Fort Laramie
Treaty, and then subsequently
lost during the Gold Rush.
The family who
originally homesteaded
Pe' Sla once it was
open decided they
were going to sell the ranch
and all of the pieces to it.
This is one of
five Lakota sites.
It's the only Lakota site that
was still in private ownership.
And we worked with six tribes,
six of the Lakota tribes,
to purchase Pe'
Sla and protect it.
That piece that
you're looking at
was subdivided before
the auction was
to be held into 22
different small ranchettes,
and they were going to
divide the prairie up.
We've maintained it.
We've bought more
property around it.
We also have work at Bear Butte,
which is also in the Black
Hills, to protect
that from encroachment
from the Sturgis Motorcycle
Rally, which by chance happens
during pretty much the same
time that all of the Sun Dances
occur and prayers
occur at Bear Butte.
As I said, we work on
large buffalo projects
because they require
large amounts of land,
and we can pick up
larger pieces of land.
The tribes are very
much interested
in using buffalo, bringing
back buffalo onto Indian lands
and using those to
support the community.
We have a 17,000-acre project
right now at Rock Creek
on the Standing
Rock Reservation,
which I think will be
a model for others.
They're putting in
a community freezer.
They're going to process
all their buffalo.
Their kids actually own
buffalo that are in the herd.
And one of the girls who
was there in their beef
program first and then came
over into buffalo as well,
she is now using
it for her tuition
to veterinary school
in North Dakota.
We work on any number of
legal reform pieces, both
at the congressional
level, but also then
at a more local level.
Especially with
state and county.
We want the states and
counties to understand
what it is to have a
sovereign tribe in the area,
and how you can work with them.
We also maintain a
fairly significant list
with legislation that's going
on as well as court cases.
At any given time
in the US Congress,
there are anywhere
from 12 to 20 bills
pending that will
affect Indian land.
Court cases are probably
100, 150 at any given
time across the country.
Out of that 100 or 150, those
that get to the Supreme Court,
when asking for cert
at the Supreme Court,
the tribes have had
three cases accepted,
and one has been successful.
All the rest are counties and
states bringing cases forward
that get accepted by
the Supreme Court.
In order to make
all that work, we've
been trying to work with
all of the tribal lands
staffs across the
country through what
has become the National
Tribal Land Association.
And we bring all the
tribal land staffs
who are interested in a
conference every year,
and we're dealing with
issues and resources
that we can bring to them.
In fact, that's where our
relationship with Raleigh
developed, was Google was
doing all of the mapping work,
and the tribes obviously
had a very high need
for getting mapping and getting
as many layers on a GIS map
as they could get on there.
And I was telling her of the one
tribe this afternoon at lunch.
They started with an eight and
a half by 11 sheet of paper
for representing their
reservation, which
was somewhere around
150 square miles.
And the allotments were just
simple red dots on there.
They had no idea
how many acres were
under each one or anything,
what the size of it was.
And we used Google
Maps, basically,
and plotted them out so
that they could at least
see what they owned.
We've been working
with families.
This is the hardest
thing we've ever done.
So we're trying
to bring families
who are co-owners on
allotments together to manage
their property collectively.
And we've had lots of families
really interested, right?
And then they have
their first meeting
and find out that they aren't
in real agreement on much.
And so we've had any
number of fits and starts
under this thing,
but we're hoping it's
going to work out eventually.
All of this led us to, I
guess-- what was it, 2007?--
we were at a point
where we kept running up
against the law that seemed to
us to be fundamentally wrong.
And so we went out and
commissioned a piece
by the American Indian
Law Resource Center
in Helena, Montana, and we
worked with legal professors
from all over the country who
specialized in Indian law.
And we went back and
looked at Indian law
starting in 1829 with
the Marshall Trilogy,
with the discussion of
the Doctrine of Discovery
and the relationship
between the tribes
who were signing treaties
and the federal government.
Thomson Reuters
published the book,
and the principles that
we developed along the way
were in fitting with
the United Nations
Declaration on the Rights
of Indigenous People.
So this was our manuscript
for how this country could
follow that doctrine and come
down to a different type of law
for Indian land.
We shortened it up a whole
bunch so that the general public
wouldn't have to read
that legal version of it.
And this is a piece that's
also available on our website,
and shorts it down to a
"Reader's Digest" version.
The last thing I'll
kind of go through here,
we have proposed to
the federal government
a social impact bond model for
funding the estate planning
work throughout the country.
You can see in the
lower right-hand corner,
it would rely on
outside investors
through a bond process.
And then the work would
get done through contracts
that ILTF, the Indian
Land Tenure Foundation,
would let to contractors.
And then that would be audited,
and the federal government
would pay in savings.
We have about 1.3 million
undivided interests
in this country on Indian
land, and each one costs on
average $120 per year for
the Bureau of Indian Affairs
to manage.
If you look at the Bureau
of Indian Affairs' budget,
it doesn't have that much money
in there for land management.
And so we know it's
not being done.
It's not being done
properly, and that's
why we're offering this to them.
Our reason for doing this was so
that Indian people could manage
their assets, so that we could
get in control of those assets.
It turns out by putting
this piece together,
as you can see by the
pink box down there,
the total savings to the
Department of Interior
would be around $5.7 billion.
And they would
get an $8.5 return
to every dollar spent to do it.
Interestingly enough, we aren't
sure that's enough for them.
[LAUGHS]
And I don't know what is.
If they can't get them there
in this time of budgets
and what they're facing
with their employment
right now at the Bureau
of Indian Affairs--
60% of their employees are
eligible for retirement
tomorrow, and
they're going to be
losing this massive workforce.
And when we presented this to
them, they said, but where will
they get jobs?
And I said, that's not
going to be an issue.
You're still going to have
plenty of jobs out there.
The other thing we
were trying to change
in the same legislation,
the same process,
in 2010, independent of
everyone else, the department
took to Congress on a change
in the American Indian probate.
Reform Act, which said all
the permanent structures
on trust land should now
be considered fee land,
meaning they separated
permanent structures on the land
from the land ownership.
And so what we've
got in Indian country
is this bifurcated ownership.
If you buy a house in
a city here on a lot,
600 years of real
estate law says
those two pieces are connected.
In Indian country,
we've separated that.
The unfortunate part is the
Bureau of Indian Affairs tracks
the trust land
underneath, and no one
tracks the ownership
of the property.
The fee property, the buildings.
And so we've got people out
there selling their trust
interest to the department,
but not selling their interest
in the other property.
And that's becoming a real
problem for housing and other
pieces in Indian country.
The other thing, 17--
18 states now, I think
maybe even 19 states now,
allow for the use of
transfer on death deeds.
So with simple estates, you can
say on the event of my death,
so-and-so gets my estate.
In Indian country,
we can't do that.
The federal government has not
passed the congressional act
that it needs to
allow us to do that.
When money comes in
from Indian land,
it goes into what's called
an individual Indian money
account.
Now some of you may
have said, jeez.
All Indians get a check, right?
From the federal government?
Well, that's actually
their rent money
coming to them through
the federal government
issues by treasury.
That account, the individual
Indian money accounts,
because the undivided
interests have gotten so small
and the number of these
accounts has grown so large
that 50,000 of those accounts
have less than $15 in them,
and accrue less than $1 a year.
If they go through
the probate process
that the federal
government has laid out,
it costs $1,000 for
an expedited probate.
And so for $15, we're paying
$1,000 in administrative fees
to probate that estate.
With a transfer on death deed,
we could save all that money,
and that's what we've
pointed out to them.
We also want to allow for
electronic wills and storage
of the originals.
So the federal government,
at least in Indian country,
is way behind the times.
And you know, talking
to this group,
I'm sure you could get on
board with this, right?
So they won't accept any
electronic documentation
of a will.
It has to be the original.
Now if you file anything
in federal district court,
you'll know that you have
to do it electronically.
They won't accept paper
pleadings anymore.
It has to be done
electronically.
But when it comes
to Indian wills,
they won't accept
an electronic will,
and we hope to change that
just simply so that people can
search the database of who
wrote a will and who didn't.
We've had about 25% of the
Office of Hearings and Appeals,
the group that does the probate,
25% of that every year is spent
on going back and
reopening probates
that they thought
there was no will for,
and then somebody said,
oh, look what I found.
All in all, I think what
happens in Indian land,
it can be somewhat summarized
by this next video.
I mean, when he put this--
when we had him filmed,
I think he pretty much
summarized for everybody how
we all feel in Indian country.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This land today where I am,
this 320 acres, my grandma's
original allotment, it means
the world to me to be here,
to see that my grandma,
she herself had a vision,
to leave something for her kids
and keep her line, so to speak,
going in her family.
And her son, which is my dad,
you know, passing it on to us
next.
And I see the same
thing happening with me,
thinking for my kids.
The land is critical to me.
Without the land, I'm lost.
I won't be me.
I won't be excited
about doing things.
I wouldn't be happy.
And I'd probably be dead.
[END PLAYBACK]
Like I said, I think
that pretty well
summarizes how an awful lot
of us in Indian country feel.
This is what happens.
This is what I feel like after
I blaze 200 years of Indian land
history in a 45-minute period.
I showed that to some people
at the University of Wisconsin.
A professor came up
to me afterwards.
I think it was still playing.
I didn't realize it
was still playing.
And she goes, you know,
that's the most incredibly
disturbing thing
I've ever seen, but I
can't take my eyes off it.
[LAUGHS]
So I'd be happy to
answer any questions
that folks might have.
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: So I've been
getting a couple questions
from the audience that's
watching the live stream,
so I'm going to start
with one of those.
There's a question
about-- it's actually
two questions kind of related.
The first is how
reclaiming Indian land
would impact Northeastern
Oklahoma where
there's a large population.
And they were curious
whether there's
going to be any additional
impact by the ongoing "Royal
versus Murphy" case.
Which, a lot of people
might not know what that is.
CRIS STAINBROOK: Yeah.
And I would hesitate to say
how far out that would go.
Let me address the first
part, because I mean,
I think we get that a lot.
We get a lot from
non-Indians as well.
Our goal really is to
get back those lands that
were promised to us.
Now there are some
pieces, especially
in Northeast Oklahoma,
where they did not
have traditional reservations.
So they had what became
known as service areas.
And we would still like to
get those areas, some lands
in those areas,
enough to support
Indian people and the tribes
back in Indian ownership.
So yes, we're out there.
The one thing I will
say for the most part,
we are not looking
for the courts
or the federal government to
return lands to the tribes
unless, of course, the
federal government still holds
that title.
On private lands,
we're expecting
and we're going to have to go
willing seller, willing buyer.
So we, in fact, help the
tribes buy that land back.
Will there be an impact
over time on an area?
What we're finding is wherever
there's a large population
of Indian people--
and this is a little
bit of one of those
no generalization is worth
a damn, not even this one.
I think Mark Twain said
that or Samuel Clemens.
Wherever you have an
Indian population,
you've got a fast
growing population.
Like, mostly young people.
And in the Plains especially,
the population of non-Indians
reached a peak generally
at the turn of the 1900s.
The homesteading caused
this big influx of people
into the Plains, and
it became apparent
fairly quickly that you
couldn't survive on 160 acres.
And so what we've
seen in the Plains--
North Dakota, South Dakota,
Eastern Montana, and Nebraska,
parts of Missouri, Kansas--
all of Kansas,
most of Oklahoma--
is that you need large tracts.
And what happens is the farmer
next door buys your tract,
and then he buys another tract.
And so we've got these
non-Indian landowners who
own big tracts of land, and
now they're 70 years old,
and they have no heirs.
And so what we're
preparing to do
is really try and
buy those back.
And the population in a
place like Northeast Oklahoma
over time will probably
start to expand again.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could explain,
you used the word undivided
units or parcels or something.
CRIS STAINBROOK:
Undivided interests.
AUDIENCE: Interests.
Thank you.
CRIS STAINBROOK: So when
the land is in probate,
going from an original
allottee, for instance,
to the next set of heirs,
the land stays intact,
but the title divides.
And so they're
undivided in the sense
that there's no physical
division of the land,
and they own it in common.
So probably the best
way to think of it
is a glass of water, and you
each own a quarter of it,
but you can't pick
out your quarter
and hold it in your hand.
That's the undivided
nature of it.
And so what it
means in the end is
you have to have a process for,
who makes decisions over that?
And we've gotten
to the point where
the Bureau of Indian Affairs has
defined that through US Code 25
as if you've got
more than 20 owners,
50% ownership has to agree
to any action on that.
If you've got--
I don't know what
it is from there.
It's like 11 to 20, then
60% have to agree to it.
And then from five to
11, 80% of ownership
has to agree to that action.
And if there's five
or less, 90% has
to agree to it, which
usually comes down to veto
power more than agreement.
But that's the undivided nature
of it is you own everything.
You can't pick out your
part and say, that's mine.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
CRIS STAINBROOK: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming here today.
How can I help?
Like, how can I get involved?
CRIS STAINBROOK:
Well, two things.
And first, let me dispense
with the one, right?
Our development
person would be angry
if I didn't say you could
support us financially.
You could do that.
I think as important to
us and the Foundation
and the Indian people is to
become aware of the situation
so that when you
hear things like,
well, you know, reservations
are just a morass of poverty,
well, we have a fair
number that are destitute.
There's no question.
But part of it is because
we lost most of the land.
And the land that we have
left is almost unmanageable
because of the
undivided interest
and the fractionated title.
And so if we want to become
productive landowners,
we need to work on
getting that back.
Being able to
inform your friends
and others of the situation.
I once said, I'd be happy
if we could get to a point
where we could show people
things like that social impact
bond piece and not
have people come out
of the woodwork to fight us just
because we're Indian, you know?
I mean, the social
impact bond piece
serves the taxpayers
of this country.
It helps us move Indian country
further forward as well,
and control our assets.
And that's what we
would like from people
is that they just become
informed around some of that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
again, as well, for coming.
So my question is
just in regards to--
I know you mentioned
that you obviously
had Google's help in
regards to the GIS mapping
and different allocation of
the allotments and whatnot.
But you also mentioned that only
currently, I think you said,
you have about 7% of wills
already written at this point.
And I also know you said you
are unable to do currently
the electronic will.
So I guess my
question for you is,
what's currently the
biggest barrier to entry
in getting people to
participate or older generations
to actually go ahead
and write that will?
And how can technology
and everyone else
help in that regard?
CRIS STAINBROOK: The
biggest impediment we've had
is we haven't had
enough people working.
So for instance, we spent--
we have gone from foundation
grant to a small grant
from the federal government
to more foundation grant money
to finally, three years
ago, we had a grant
from the Office
of Special Trustee
to do three years
of will writing.
But it's been this
happenstance of funding
to keep people in the field.
When we first started,
people said, well,
Indian people won't
talk about death.
And in fact, they won't.
But they'll talk about where
their assets are going.
And that's what we
wanted them to do,
and they're more than
willing to do that.
We always end up in
a three-year project.
At the end of the
project, we'll end up
with 200 wills in
process, but not done.
And that's why we want to
do the social impact bond,
because it's of a scale
where we can move--
I mean, you write the wills.
Most of our clients
are 65 to 90 years old,
and that's why we can't
get more than 7%, right?
Because we go out and we write
all these wills, we go back,
we test it.
We're probably at 7% because
we lost a bunch of people
along the way.
The wills were probated.
[LAUGHS]
That's the nature
of the business.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw in your first
slide that you
said, like, the goal
of the foundation
is to reclaim all
the land that still
retains aboriginal interest.
And I was wondering
what exactly that means,
and how do you determine that?
Is it just all the lands that
were promised at some point
to the Indians, or what is that?
CRIS STAINBROOK: Yeah.
The actual language of that is
inside the original reservation
boundaries.
And so that's the
90 million acres
that we lost that were
promised to the exclusive use
and occupation by Indian people.
And then the aboriginal
pieces of that
are those places outside
of the reservation boundary
where they still
hold an interest
for cultural or
religious reasons.
But the 90 million is all
interior to the boundaries.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
CRIS STAINBROOK: Yep.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
RALEIGH SEAMSTER: Thank
you so much to Cris
for coming for this talk.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.